hey guys what's up bandit here it's been
a big day i've been sitting here frame
by framing this trailer
for a few hours now um and i'm going a
little bit insane
gonna take a break here in a second but
i wanted to share something with you
guys
uh that i found in this trailer that i
already shared on twitter but i just
wanted to bring it over to youtube real
quick okay so you guys remember this
part of the trailer right here where it
just kind of zooms out and you can see
links standing on one of these
flying presumably zonai platforms you
can actually see a little bit of like
legitimate actual hyrule down here and
one of the key giveaways that this is
hyrule are these
tall mushroom things that we see in the
hyrule ridge
using zelda dungeon's interactive map of
breath of the wild as
shown here i started to cross-reference
what we can see here in the trailer
with the actual map of breath of the
wild and i was actually able to very
accurately pinpoint
exactly where this is it's right here
as you can see it's as if link is
standing on a flying platform right here
and looking this way
and what we can see from that angle
lines up exactly
with the already existing map of breath
of the wild now what's interesting about
this that i want to share with you guys
very quickly is that there is something
missing from hyrule as shown in the
recent trailer
if you look at the rightmost hill
pictured here which would be the
southwestern portion of the hyrule ridge
you'll notice that this middle platform
in this hill is missing
zonai pillars here are the screenshots
that i already uploaded to twitter with
the
uh pillars that i'm talking about
circled in red as you can see they are
very clearly present on this middle
platform in the game breath of the wild
but yet in the trailer they are nowhere
to be
found and there's five of them and
they're pretty decently sized so we
should be able to see them especially
this one that's nestled right here
beside this rock which should be visible
immediately to the right but as we can
see in the trailer there is absolutely
nothing there now what this tells me is
that there's a very good possibility
that what we are looking at right here
is not hyrule as we know it in the main
game but rather an
older version of hyrule an ancient
version of hyrule since
those pillars would have been man-made
and this appears to be before they
were made as far as what this implies
yadda yadda i'll be doing theories about
it later on in the week but for now i
think i'm going to
pump the brakes a little bit and allow
my brain to i don't know go to sleep or
something like that anyway be sure to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already to stick around for all the
theories to come
like this video to get it spread around
on youtube and let me know what you
think of what i found here in the
comments below this is mazintinabandit
signing out for the third time today
peace